hello and welcome to this video playing
net roast 2000 okay i want i want a
banker can't they i'm experimenting with
this decline in of any bankers and
Bernoulli's they often play this gambit
language I don't believe as that great
even though I just play it by ear to be
honest I just know that this is set up
it's not the only one but I'm just
copying what I have seen in games by
younger self so nobody's that this is
not great for black so I'm I just have
this knowledge not much more okay one
problem for black layer sometimes that
you get that porn back but the resulting
position is still not that great because
of there's some weaknesses that you have
we'll see how he continues to develop
maybe with Bishop to f5 one weakness I
said you for pond even if you win d 5
back here sometimes have issues with
some some weak squares for example he am
ok 95 mm no i don't i'm not taking you
for that looks wrong but after just
takes hoop take some i think he's got
some some rather substantial weaknesses
ok this is something that i had on the
board just very recently in a blitz game
against someone with the handle salma
hayek i remember that game 97 and the d6
was this kit was that some higher game
where I spoiled a very very good
position ok um Knight to c6 Wow
ok so if I move like Queen he will take
d5 I guess mmm yeah probably probably
well but I can go to be three right
where's what is this if i go to be 3 90
x and it takes everything I've got 9 p-6
at the end which wins material so it
probably has to move the night yeah for
example them ok now a couple of options
you just want us to just just take it
but not sure about about this also have
g6
I'm not sure about it I'd like to get
rid of his bishop that the bishop is
often often dangerous and so I'm making
sure that this is this is now gone my
development however is not good this is
definitely definitely the case i hope
that 94 here will be the move that helps
me to coordinate this position ok this
one too tough yes got those attacking
idea see on the kingside Bishop g4 for
example very unclear position or 94 yeah
so same idea between h4 and stuff like
that
very dangerous
very dangerous might be huge if a middle
that looks for okay I'm I'm taking stuff
here simply to reduce them attacking
potential a little bit even though the
Ducks the light squares get get terribly
weak right f3 is the thing that that in
depth that deeply irritates me 93
King edge one teenager stuff like that
yeah takes takes it just it's just not
not going to work
not even some kind of so they can so
I'll continue the game this is I know
take scoop do you understand maybe I
cannot go Quincy five at least 26 and
sometimes they have 58 a queen the air
still don't believe I can defend yet it
just looks too bad oops g6 however they
do I don't see a direct when maybe you
can just take a look at the tech it's
very lightly winning
yeah I have to take it
ok so root G success is what he wants to
do if i go Queen everyone
this is a strong move iam I have to have
to get some some pieces of one otherwise
i can never move my bishop piazza ok f4
I guess I see gets older and older books
now in the game ok I should be able to
defend him I would make like one or two
more moves and I don't have those moves
and I woke age five look aged five is a
winning move
okay age five Queen eternity okay yeah
at least I know what to do time for me
now
it would be a full-blown miracle if I'm
not losing here currently I don't see
you in which is probably not really the
case there should be a win for black and
now he's threatening this and this but I
can go here I'd okay that was that was
the point I couldn't defend I couldn't
defend this position not anymore okay
white / sinus so yeah that's it's a very
interesting line I mean Nexus 6 very
interesting move I thought this this
looks very normal probably the six is
wrong then I mean it lose this time I
wanted to get rid of this bishop and I
don't know I didn't want this you know
where the bishop is coming over here
this is looking dangerous and this is
why I went is six but probably this is
just too dangerous with the rookie and
this can now this is this is too
dangerous this is too dangerous I am
already using this is a tech is too
strong really is too strong so this is
the six ideas this is bad i mean i don't
know i mean i don't know this opening
line so i can only guess but I think
this this looks very very normal maybe
yeah maybe
maybe I should try to improve with night
b3 and this position and a queen bee
three I'm sorry queen bee three at PG
seven and it leads to the same position
as in the game the engine to suggest
Bishop d2 here and says this is roughly
equal I know I don't like it
particularly knight c6 is very good add
the success more or less more or less
losing rope during k rook the oneness is
even as better by the computer it ok
after a while it sees that this is also
a fantastic attack I'm just not
developed here the idea is just winning
I cannot really defend this angle yeah
this is all so sorry also check wind but
what he did is fine I mean he just
attacks with all the pieces there is no
defense I played the relatively best
moves but it is just losing check now
that was nicely played I was nicely
played as i mentioned i don't really
believe in this opening for black but it
probably requires much more precision
than then i had here in this game but he
played well what can you do ok thanks
for watching guys